logan paul
uh mike asked us this morning about the
phone call and the billion dollars in
happiness actually uh mike tyson wanted
me to fight him uh-huh
call logan paul oh call logan paul colt
yeah come on man make it happen
i don't think he's not interested in
fight guys
i love you mike now we got this guy
but now we got a real challenger what's
up
what's up would you step up what up baby
how's it going congrats on a good fight
thank you brother and likewise let's get
logan message the
let's get logan paul the message logan
but this is where i get confused like
like who's right and who's wrong
it's even
hard just to try to stand next to this
fire imagine being thrown in it and paul
logan that's the answer to your first
question you saw the message i invited
you to something priceless logan i'm
inviting you again but this is where i
get confused like like who's right and
who's wrong are are muslims wrong
because they're muslim
are christians wrong because they're
christian
and what are the consequences of being
right and wrong what is it what's the
consequence if we get it wrong if we if
we fail to test this test of life
you'd respect me less if i didn't tell
you the truth the truth is that abraham
moses noah all these messengers muhammad
just being the last of message in a
chain of messengers who came with the
same message to worship the one
and only creator of the heavens and
earth there's not multiple gods and you
can i'm sure you watched that video
their god yes okay
you know uh
in islam
allah is is the god and judaism jesus is
the god and uh
jesus is not god he never called people
to worship him
as a god as a literal son of god he
called people to worship the one god
along without associates and he also
warned people of the hellfire and he
gave the glad tidings of paradise
eternal life in the next
paradise and so did all the other
messengers they came with that same
message not
contradictory messages
one coming and saying worship me the
other one coming worship the song the
other one won't come saying worship the
moon the other one saying worship money
no that's where you're confused now we
got
badu jack
and he's giving you an invitation what's
the invitation you're a fight promoter
too
another thing is i want to i want him to
sit and do uh do a a nice meeting with
you guys i think he can benefit from
your friendship
because i'm i'm confused but the
messengers that the creator sent he
they came to bring you out of the
confusion
and prophet muhammad is just the last
and final messenger sent to mankind so
the consequence again to answer your
question
and what are the consequences of being
right and wrong is the hellfire and i
hope that you respect that person more
who's giving you the truth
straightforward
because that's not that's not a true
love now logan we've you know we've
crossed paths a couple of times with
logan because we worked with ksi for the
first fight
and um you know
and you got to give the kid credit you
know i mean he has really turned his
life around and he and he's and he's
maximizing his his platform and good for
him yeah good for him yes
he's also been on kind of like a
spiritual journey if you watch some of
his has he no i i've been with him he's
kind of been you know talking about this
down the other end i get it
money doesn't buy happiness
it actually pushes happiness away i'm
starting to believe that i i truly do
believe that money is quite honestly the
root of evil psychologists say they've
found the exact amount of money you need
to be happy
2018 article this study analyzed data
from over 1.7 million people in 164
countries the ideal income for
individuals is 95 000 a year for life
satisfaction and 60 to 75 000 a year for
emotional well-being
the study published in the journal
nature human behavior found that once
the threshold was reached further
increases in income were actually
associated with reduced happiness
researchers defined life satisfaction as
an overall assessment of how one is
doing while emotional well-being refers
to a person's day-to-day feelings such
as happiness sadness excitement and
anger this is the final part there's a
happiness tipping point the more you
have the more you want the study
concluded it's interesting when people
go through that and they turn to uh all
these different things you know um
you have these rocks and then the buddha
and then all the you know different
things superstitions but you rub the
stomach for good luck
[Music]
that's the beautiful what you mentioned
the word earlier tohid when people
really and i've had so many guests over
the years they've experimented with
everything and anything but when they
really got to experience islam
submission to the creator not the
creation then it was like wow now it's
like you got counterfeit and then you
got the real deal right real thing so
that's why if because you guys have
access to many people man did you guys
ever go out to lunch ever you know kick
it with each other with the logan paul
no no no no no we were always on
opposite sides of the sword yeah you
know we were with the ksi team oh okay
is that it has that been set now that's
like okay now you can't cross over uh
you know i mean
i don't know if it's set set but ksi
beat him right he did yeah you did and
you you helped traino uh actually you
know i sparred actually this was
probably 2018. yeah so he called me it's
like a youtube kid that's going to come
in can you please spar with him he's
huge in the youtube world i just never
heard of him and then so we did a little
video um you know i dropped him with a
body shot
you know a little sparring just for fun
and uh yeah and then he was like he got
40 million he's the biggest youtuber in
the world or whatever they're gonna have
a boxing fight against logan paul
and
well i didn't really know either by
seeing his face around but uh yeah and
um
then they fought so i walked him to the
ring
he begged he begged me said please what
i don't want to get involved in these
youtubers i said please man there's good
marketing and everything else all right
and he's actually a nice kid ksi i
actually like the kid he's very nice
yeah he's a good kid so that goes back
to what i was saying you just have no
idea like from that mexican cartel
uh individual you know who i interviewed
and he's somewhere in mexico with the
cartel and now he's muslim he ends up
accepting islam alhamdulillah you just
don't know what kind of impression you
know what you're going to say or do that
can leave a lasting impression on many
people who are watching they're looking
you know your example what you're saying
you know
so that's why every time we post
something on social media you always got
to think a little extra you know it's
one thing if we just us but you gotta i
love it the young kids are those you
know following us so we got to think
before
even sometimes you want to respond to to
haters online but then you think about
it i'm a muslim i can right i can't do
it you know masha'allah allahu akbar and
that's not a war cry that's praising me
this is so important they in this day
and age